[Applaudissements]
j'avais deux objectifs dans ma vie le
premier c'était être cadre dans une
multinationale avant 30 ans est le
deuxième c'était avoir un salaire d'un
million de francs suisses par année
avant 40 ans alors le premier objectif a
été atteint et le deuxième n'est plus
vraiment d'actualité
enfin si vous voulez me faire un don je
suis preneur mais l'idée même de gravir
les échelons d'une multinationale pour
amasser un maximum d'argent est
totalement absurde pour moi aujourd'hui
après un parcours dans le domaine de
l'économie et de la finance un parcours
académique j'ai travaillé dans un
cabinet d'audit une banque et finalement
une multinationale
donc la voie vers un succès très relatif
était toute tracée mais voilà qu'au bout
de dix ans dans ce milieu là je me suis
retrouvé face à un mur
un mur fait de valeurs de conviction et
ça m'a stoppé net sur cette voie toute
tracée
ce que j'ai constaté c'est que on a
souvent des
des choix que l'on fait qui nous mène à
certains endroits et d'ailleurs je vais
vous poser une petite question très
simple qu'est ce qui fait que vous
faites le métier que vous faites
aujourd'hui vous pensez que c'est le
fruit du hasard ou que ça vient d'un
raisonnement vraiment réfléchi prenez 5
secondes pour vous pour vous poser cette
question et répondre de manière vraiment
honnête
qu'est ce qui fait que vous exercez
votre métier aujourd'hui
alors voilà peut-être que vous avez les
réponses ou pas la première observation
que j'ai fait suite à cette prise de mur
a été que mes choix avait été dictée
principalement par des normes sociales
par des injonctions par des croyances et
par une certaine idée de la réussite et
ce qui est incroyable avec les croyances
incroyable avec les croyances je n'ai
pas prévu
c'est que elles agissent comme un filtre
en fait devant nous comme des lunettes
que l'on porte et au bout de quelques
temps on se rend plus compte qu'on voit
le monde à travers ses lunettes et ont
fini par prendre nos croyances pour la
réalité
la deuxième observation que j'ai fait à
propos de de ce changement c'est que le
moment entre lequel je me suis rendu
compte que je n'étais pas sur mon sur
sur le bon chemin en fait est le moment
où j'ai changé pour rejoindre donc cette
fondation compétences bénévoles il s'est
passé plusieurs années alors certes les
changements prennent du temps mais quand
même plusieurs années vous me direz ça
fait beaucoup et
j'arrivais à me persuader que j'étais
sur le bon chemin en me disant que je
serais heureux sur ce chemin lorsque
j'aurai une équipe à gérer ou lorsque
j'aurai un salaire plus élevé et j'ai
remarqué que ça marchait pas vraiment
comme ça donc très branlant comme
théorie
donc j'étais incapable de me projeter
dans une autre vision du succès
et c'est seulement plus tard que j'ai
compris que le changement devait pas
venir avec une condition mais c'était
plutôt des signaux interne à écouter et
en termes de changements françoise dolto
a écrit à un très bon bouquin sur le
changement qui s'adresse plutôt aux
adolescents elle parle du complexe du
homard vous connaissez le complexe du
homard
plutôt pas moi non plus je le
connaissais pas avant la semaine passée
et elle explique que le homard pour
faire sa mue pour grandir en quelque
sorte
il doit enlever sa carapace
et se retrouver dans un état d'extrême
vulnérabilité pour ensuite pouvoir
grandir et reconstruire sa carapace d'où
cette métaphore avec l'adolescence où on
passe de l'enfance à l'âge adulte et ça
s'applique aussi à tous les changements
que l'on effectué dans notre vie on
passe d'un état qui est connue vers un
état de désir et qu'on ne connaît pas et
durant cette phase de changement on se
retrouve dans une phase de vulnérabilité
de perte de repères
qu'il faut en quelque sorte acceptée qui
peut être désagréable et j'ai cette
image qui me vient souvent c'est que
lorsqu'on veut attraper quelque chose
souvent on tient fort ce qu'on connaît
on tient très fort et si on le tient ça
nous empêche d'attraper le sever qu'on
veut aller donc on est obligé de lâcher
prise pour aller vers ce changement
la 3ème observation que j'ai fait
suite à ce changement de carrière c'est
que le prix à payer pour continuer sur
cette voie sur laquelle j'étais était
beaucoup trop élevé
en plus pour être sur la mauvaise voie
c'est à dire fatigue chronique
anxiété chronique également est beaucoup
moins temps pour mon couple pour mes
hobbies
et tout ça comme je les dis venait d'une
vision extrêmement étriquée du succès
parce que moi je pensais que le succès
c'était vraiment ce chemin là et qu'il
n'y avait pas d'autres possibilités est
d'ailleurs une petite anecdote lorsque
j'ai changé mon de métier je suis passé
d'une telle multinationale à une
structure à but non lucratif une
personne n'est venu me dire quelques
mois après la prise de mon poste
ça va ton petit job
est
alors au moins savait le mérite d'être
clair c'était certes un peu brutal mais
ça avait le mérite de montrer sa vision
à elle du succès et ma vision
aujourd'hui a énormément changé pour moi
le succès c'est d'exercer quelque chose
qui nous fait vibrer pour lequel on se
lève le matin ça fait du sens pour nous
et c'est complètement différent que
d'être sur une voie toute tracée avec un
seul objectif ça nous ouvre justement
les oeillères
donc en résumé j'étais pas sur la bonne
voie le prix à payer pour être sur cette
voie était beaucoup trop élevé
et les choix qu'ils m'avaient amené sur
cette voie n'était pas vraiment les
miens puisque découlait de normes
sociales
donc voilà voilà le tableau et qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ça vous me direz alors
ce que j'ai choisi de faire c'est de
passer à l'action et je vais vous
présenter deux actions qui ont eu un
changement s'unit significatif sur ma
vie le premier la première action ça a
été de me former je me suis formé au
coaching et à la pnl
alors je me posais pas la question
quelle est elle l'argent que je pouvais
gagner avec ses diplômes mais c'était
plutôt qu'elle était la joie que je
pouvais avoir d'apprendre de nouvelles
choses et de rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes
et tout ça ça a eu un déclic pour moi
est ce que je peux vous encourager à
faire parce qu'on est dans un monde où
les changements vont très vite où on
voit avec la robotisation
l'automatisation
aussi l'émergence l'émergence du big
data de l'intelligence artificielle les
métiers que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
certains vont disparaître et d'autres
vont changer radicalement donc si vous
voulez investir en vous
prenez le choix de l'investissement dans
votre formation et dans de vous former
dans quelque chose qui vous tient à
coeur qui vous fait vibrer
la deuxième action que j'ai entreprises
a été de ralentir et oui on peut bien
ralentir prendre une action de ralentir
seulement si on donne du sens j'ai
constaté que j'étais constamment dans la
vitesse dans la comparaison à d'autres
personnes et cela m'a mené pas grand
chose de positif
donc j'ai fait ce choix de ralentir
suite à un travail avec un thérapeute
qui pratiquent la psychologie
existentielle et on s'est rendu compte
avec ce thérapeute que mon envie d'aller
vite c'était pas une vraie envie d'aller
vite c'était plus un mécanisme de
défense
qui empêchait une certaine partie de moi
de s'exprimer
est alors sans rentrer dans les domaines
de la psychanalyse il ya aussi là un
lien très étroit avec la mort où une
fuite en avant deux pour semer la mort
mais au final on m'a expliqué qu'elle
était déjà en moi avec des milliards de
cellules qui mouraient chaque jour là
j'ai vraiment flippé
ensuite on m'a dit qu'elle se régénérer
alors là ça allait beaucoup mieux et je
me tiens à sa
et donc c'est un combat quotidien non
pas contre la vitesse mais pour un
rythme juste c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
je travaille à temps partiel je prends
du temps avec ma fille je fais du sport
plusieurs fois par semaine ça commence à
payer
et c'est vraiment dans chaque action que
je fais au quotidien en essayant d'être
présent et non pas en pensant de ce que
je vais faire ce soir ou ce que je donne
tout ce que je dois faire pour la fin de
la semaine
voilà j'ai énormément parler de moi
maintenant j'aimerais qu'on parle un peu
de vous si ça vous convient donc je
pense qu on partage tous en commun
l'objectif d'être heureux dans nos vies
respectives
l'argent est une des clés pour accéder à
un certain niveau de bonheur par contre
beaucoup détruit des études ont démontré
que passé un certain niveau de revenus
même si on augmente notre venue ça
n'apportera pas une plus grand un plus
grand bonheur c'est à dire que si
aujourd'hui votre venue vous permet de
payer votre loyer
votre alimentation vos hobbies
d'augmenter votre revenu ça va pas vous
rendre plus heureux là je vous enlève
peut-être un poids vous pouvez passer
votre temps à faire autre chose que de
travailler et aussi j'ai trouvé une
autre définition du bonheur qui a été
décrite par un philosophe dont je n'ai
pas retrouvé le nom et qui parle lui non
pas du bonheur mais de la bonne heure
je m'explique il dit que cette recherche
constante de légèreté et de bien-être
qu'est le bonheur ça n'existe pas tout
simplement et que ce sont plutôt des
petits moments dans la journée
qui font qu'on se sent bien léger
donc je vous invite à partir de ce soir
à prendre conscience de tous ces petits
moments dans la journée qui font que
vous vous direz tient là c'est la bonne
heure
une autre raison peut-être de changer
notre vision de la réussite et peut-être
aussi d'opérer des changements dans vos
vies c'est un bouquin qui a été écrit
par brown i were deux semaines de
d'entraînement la prononciation et elle
parle justement des personnes des cinq
regret des personnes en fin de vie et
l'un de ses regrets c'est d'avoir
travaillé autant alors peut-être dans
cette salle il ya des personnes qui
mettent au centre de leur vie le travail
et on n'est pas là pour juger pour dire
si c'est bien ou pas même si j'ai ma
petite idée
simplement soyez au clair avec vous même
2 pourquoi vous le fait qu est ce que
vous êtes qu'est ce que cela vous
apporte et aussi qu'est ce que cela vous
coûte et quel sens vous donnez à votre
travail
est peut-être une des raisons majeures
pour moi d'opérer des changements dans
votre vie
la raison principale c'est que je pense
que là haut niveau de l'humanité on
arrive à un petit tournant où
la présence même de l'homme sur terre et
un peu remise en question alors pour
ceux qui lisent un peu les médias je
crois que les signaux sont ça c'est un
signal
[Musique]
sont plutôt au rouge pour les plus
optimistes on dire orange en termes de
dérèglement climatique crise migratoire
etc etc et je pense qu'en tant
qu'individu on ne peut pas porter tous
ces changements sur nos épaules
déjà pour la simple et bonne raison
qu'on ne maîtrise pas une grande
majorité des paramètres et je sais pas
si vous avez déjà vu quelqu'un essayait
de s'acharner sur quelque chose qu'il ne
maîtrise pas c'est pas beau à voir et
les résultats sont rarement rendez vous
donc ce que je vous propose
ça se résume dans le titre d'un livre
que j'ai lu récemment qui s'appelle se
changer changer le monde c'est à dire
que si vous voulez tout simplement voir
du changement autour de vous
ça doit d'abord venir de l'intérieur de
vous dans vos pensées dans votre coeur
et ensuite se traduire en comportement
puis en habitude
la diversité des options que nous avons
dans notre vie est très vaste et souvent
nous en percevons qu'un petit
pourcentage
donc je vous invite à ouvrir votre
vision à prendre conscience de cela et à
faire les changements qui sont
pertinents et qui font du sens pour vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]